one welcome into another
special edition of market takes i'm your
host dion rabone reporter at the wall
street journal
we got another one today we are talking
about today's consumer price index
report aka cpi aka the inflation report
uh for july
just came out this morning at 8 30 a.m
eastern time um man if you weren't
watched it you missed a an entertaining
one an exciting one as far as data
releases go uh but you know what you're
here right now you're tuned in with me i
know you could have been anywhere in the
world and you're now you're right here
so i appreciate that we are gonna dive
into all things cpi all things inflation
we're gonna talk about of course the
market's reaction we're going to get
into all of that and talk about what
this means big picture for the federal
reserve for the economy and all of that
so thank you so much for tuning in to
this live stream again i'm dion robon
from the wall street journal look uh
today's cpi report we're going to talk
about the headline right but we're also
going to get into the core numbers and
what those mean and what this tells us
about the trajectory of inflation and
the economy we're going to talk about
how this report compared to expectations
as well as the most interesting part
kind of got to dig into the report a
little bit to get into that but we're
also going to talk about the biggest
takeaway for the market and the biggest
takeaway for the economy
what that we got from today's cpi report
so look enough talk let's get into it
let's dive right in today's report
showed inflation year over year was 8.5
percent and 0 are unchanged from the
previous month so what that means
inflation is slowing down it is cooling
in june inflation was at 9.1 percent uh
that was the highest in 41 years we are
still at those highs but again we're
cooling down now inflation was expected
to come in at 8.7
this month so even lower than that we're
seeing inflation cool and cool by more
than expected by economist that is a
good sign that's why you're seeing a lot
of green on your screen right now if
you're looking at the stock market if
you're looking at you know just most
assets
you can see the the
move upwards move higher in bullish
sentiment
importantly
the overall trend right now is cooling
and that's what the federal reserve
wants
that's what markets want
that's what folks that who are you know
going out to the grocery store going to
the gas pump that's what they want uh
but but but which used to be one of my
favorite uh little you know notes there
in my newsletter the headline from bls
today was
fallen gasoline offsets shelter food
increases so
keep in mind the big the reason that
inflation was unchanged from the
previous month was that overall you had
an increase or pickup in core inflation
but you had this huge decrease
in gas prices or huge deceleration in
the rate of increase for gas prices
so you're seeing a overall unchanged
from last month report and up 8.5 from
the month before gas prices have been
falling for about two months straight
now we are down to about four dollars
and one cent a gallon according to aaa
that's the national average that's about
a dollar below where they were at the
june all-time high and look i don't
think it's any kind of coincidence that
that june all-time high in gas kind of
correlated with the june low for the
year that we saw from the s p 500 the
stock market because inflation is very
correlated with all assets right now it
is all about inflation um
look as we as we get in the report
gas prices down significantly about more
than seven percent almost eight percent
down for the month uh but the other
piece of that is that the shelter and
food indexes are up significantly food
index up around 11
year-over-year that's the largest
12-month increase since the period
ending may 1979. 1979 so food prices
increasing significantly especially at
the grocery store the food at home cost
where a lot more folks are shopping
right now where a lot more folks are
getting their food because a lot of
people have stopped going out prices
have just gotten too expensive for them
so they're going to the grocery store
that's where we're seeing the most
significant acceleration of prices and
we saw again the biggest increase in
food prices year over year since may of
1979. food index up one percent in july
the seventh consecutive increase of
point nine percent or more what al what
that means is we're seeing consistent
increases in food prices that's
something that is not slowing down it's
not moving in the opposite direction
definitely keep your eye on food prices
the other big but
in this report is shelter the shelter
index continued to rise but a smaller
increase than we saw in june
0.5 percent in july compared to 0.6
percent in june not a lot of solace
there for folks who are seeing those
rent prices just rise and rise and rise
on them those rent prices up
significantly you saw the shelter index
up around six percent year over year um
that accounted for about 40
of the total increase in all items less
food and injury aka the core cpi
increase 40 of that was the increase in
shelter uh rent you know owner
equivalent rent if you own your house
etc etc also big increase in used cars
and trucks uh new vehicles as well as
motor vehicle insurance airline fares up
28 year-over-year even though they were
down for the month uh so look
let's look at that core cpi right you
know the fed always talks about core cpi
let's let's strip out food and energy
because those those prices are volatile
they move around a lot well the core now
is starting to look like the problem
that was the kind of ray of sunshine
that you saw a little bit okay well
overall inflation is spiking higher and
moving up higher but at least these core
prices
aren't jumping like that so we're seeing
core inflation which is what the fed
feels like it's more of what they can
control it also is is kind of a you know
a look forward to the economy for them
they say okay core cpi we've heard this
from multiple fed members including fed
chair jerome powell that core cpi tells
them more about the future than overall
cpi well right now core cpi was expected
to rise 6.1 percent rose 5.9
but you did see that month-over-month
increase in core whereas it didn't
increase overall
all that means is
food and energy when you when you strip
them out
prices are still rising and that could
mean the fed has more work to do wall
street may be a little too excited about
this report and what it means for the
federal reserve um that's telling us
that core prices and inflation could be
a little stickier than maybe a lot of
folks are thinking about and remember
month over month the cpi last month rose
by the highest amount since october of
2005 so getting this unchanged report
you know when you think of it that way
that takes a little bit of the shine off
but like i said let's talk about markets
let's talk about that market reaction
stocks as i told you took off bond
yields are down the dollar is down big
uh we're going to talk about commodities
the nasdaq up more than two percent uh
the s p 500 up 1.75
you're seeing yields down across the
board but you know still still hanging
up there uh just a little bit and of
course uh the dollar like i said down
more than one percent overall
when we look over at commodities right
when we look at commodity prices because
those have been telling us a lot about
the overall economy very interesting
reaction from oil oil spiked up higher
immediately after the report but then it
came down oil prices are now down about
two percent uh for wti u.s crude and
down about two percent for brent crude
as well dropping below that ninety
dollars a barrel level uh natural gas
prices down really oil prices and gas
down across the board very interesting
gold and silver rallied big on this gold
about one and a half percent silver up
nearly one percent but i think the
biggest piece of this is what we're
seeing in copper aka dr copper
copper really rallying up almost two
percent on this news uh down to about
one and a half percent right now but
still a big move in copper the other
move that i think is interesting is the
dollar we have seen more and more
companies kind of start to come out and
complain about how the dollar is too
strong it's cutting into profits it's
hurting earnings you know a lot of
that's just talk but we are seeing the
most companies complain about the strong
dollar that we have since 2015 so that's
seven years now
more companies complaining then if you
remember the dollar was at its previous
peak uh from around that time period
going back to the 2002 so-called dollar
strengthening cycle so we have seen this
year more companies complaining about
the strong dollar than at any time since
2015 that is significant because it is
dealing a blow to some of those overseas
sales and profits that a lot of these
multinational companies that are driving
stocks higher rely on
look microsoft pointed to the dollar
being too strong biogen costco hewlett
packard sales force companies across the
board that do a lot of business overseas
they're all saying man the dollar is too
strong so definitely something to keep
your eye on clearly inflation was a big
thing driving the dollar higher because
there were expectations for the federal
reserve to keep raising rates to be
moving faster than other central banks
well if inflation is going to cool that
starts to cool that theme and we could
see maybe a bit of a virtuous cycle with
the dollar weakening
as inflation cools down again we've seen
that usually those two things don't go
together usually as you get a weakening
dollar you get higher inflation we've
seen recently higher inflation and a
stronger dollar we could be seeing the
reversal of that right now and that
could be very good for stocks very good
for the market overall
so
clearly what the market is telling us
right now is that investors think the
fed is poised to reverse course they're
they're counting on another powell pivot
pow pivot 2.0 where you know the fed has
been pounding the table fed chair jerome
powell's been pounding the table saying
we must get inflation under control
everything in my power you know that's
priority number one two three four and
five
and the market's expecting in september
thanks to this report that the fed's
going to say okay well you know what
inflation is important but we got to
look at these job numbers baby we got to
start looking at economic growth those
things aren't looking so good so maybe
we don't need to hike as much
if you look at fed fund futures rates we
are seeing those drop across the board
showing that investors now expect the
fed to pre to hike 50 basis points
instead of 75 aka raise the rate at
twice the normal pace instead of three
times the normal pace that they have
done in recent history uh that's a big
relief because higher rates essentially
make things more expensive for companies
makes it harder to grow
and so if they're the fed's not going to
do as much in september and through the
rest of the year which is what the
market is pricing in that's a good thing
for the stock market and it's a good
thing for the economy as well because
it's less expensive to borrow those
borrowing costs we know get passed on to
consumers
so this report goes against what we've
heard from the federal reserve the
federal reserve speakers from powell at
that last press conference on through
the past few weeks have said we are not
done fighting inflation we've got a lot
more to do
let's see if the cho the tone changes
now that we've gotten this lower than
expected cpi report that it looks like
the trend is our friend again the other
question is you know are is the fed
going to be a little once bitten twice
shy are they going to say
uh well you know we thought inflation
peaked in march so we don't want to get
ahead of ourselves we've still got to do
everything in our power to get it down
or are they going to come out and
celebrate this report and say hey you
know what inflation's doing exactly what
we wanted to do
we are ready to kind of pump the brakes
on pumping the brakes
we'll see how that goes we are not going
to hear from any fomc voters today or
for the rest of the week but we do get a
couple fed speakers we get chicago fed
president charles evans and we get
minneapolis fed president neil kashgari
speaking later today you want to tune in
to see what they say
and we get married daily from the san
francisco fed tomorrow uh interesting to
see how they tap into the sentiment the
overall sentiment of the fed and how the
market reacts to what they have to say
so stepping back let's step back a
little bit we talked about the fed we
talked about the market we talked about
the overall cpi report let's talk about
the economy for a second what does this
tell us about the economy well we've
seen lower gas prices like i said
earlier
for about two months now every day for
about the past two months gas prices
have been getting lower and lower and
lower we're moving towards a virtuous
cycle on that lower gas prices help
everybody because it means it costs less
to deliver costs less to get things
where they need to go cost less the heat
less to cool lower gas prices are a good
thing and we have seen lower gas prices
into august as well so that suggests
that we could have another lower cpi
report
for august
as we've seen gas prices continue to
decline like i said gas prices down
about a dollar from their june
record high
lowered ex lowered inflation
expectations that we've seen through fed
surveys like the new york fed survey
that we that came out earlier this week
as well as uh investors lowered
expectations those 10-year break-even
rates five-year five-year forwards if
you watch my video about four signals
that investors pricing in recession i
talked about those go watch that if you
haven't watched that but we've seen
market signals that show that these
inflation expectations are coming down
but
recession expectations are increasing
lower inflation is is good for both of
those decreases inflation expectations
and could potentially decrease recession
expectations we shall see
clearly gas prices are driving a lot of
consumer expectations so if gas prices
continue to come down does the fed need
to do as much work that's the big
question because the fed doesn't do a
lot to control gas prices the stock
market bounce that we've seen we're
seeing that continue today watch that
rally because if stocks don't continue
to rise we could be seeing a little bit
of you know by the rumor we're seeing by
the rumor and by the news right now with
this boom higher in stock prices but
that could come off as folks start to
maybe question the narrative and like i
said watch those two fed speakers if
they start to pour a little cold water
on this narrative you could see the
market start to turn around either later
today or in the future
we also have seen these expectations for
rate hike come down that's big and of
course the jobs report that we saw that
really spiked inflation expectations
because the more jobs you had the more
pressure there is on wages uh the more
that inflation is going to move higher
at least that's the narrative well it
doesn't seem like wages are driving
inflation it seems like a lot of gas is
driving inflation shelter's driving
inflation food prices are driving
inflation
not wages so again maybe the fed needs
to do less that's that's something that
we need to definitely keep our eye on
so look what's next like i said we've
got those fed speakers coming up today
and tomorrow definitely watch those
those are going to be key um
housing reports next week we get a bunch
of housing reports nahb
housing confidence we'll get housing
starts building permits
those are going to be key to telling us
about this shelter component have the
fed's rate hikes really put the put the
rise in housing prices in the clamps
and and does that set a new narrative do
we get this pal pivot the market is
expecting
watch out for the ppi report tomorrow
that's the producer price index and aka
wholesale prices what are businesses
paying for the goods that they're buying
because we know businesses are passing
those costs onto consumers also export
import index on friday that's going to
put us on recession watch again what are
those export import prices telling us
about inflation and what are they
telling us about the state of the
economy because too much exports buying
and not enough
or sorry too much import buying not
enough export selling is really what's
doing a number on those uh q gdp reports
in terms of what we're seeing for u.s
growth also one week from today we will
get u.s retail sales that's going to be
a big one i hope you will be right here
with me tuned in we're going to do
another market take special cpi or sorry
special live stream on the retail sales
report on wednesday a week from today so
be there or be a
don't do that to yourself
um all right listen that's gonna do it
for me we we have talked about just
about everything in that report go forth
and prosper i urge you to do that and uh
like i said dionne bowen with the wall
street journal this has been our special
cpi live stream for market takes i hope
you will join us next week when we are
talking all things u.s retail sales be
here again 10 a.m and uh